[Music]
why would you have a big mansion
guests can't arrive through the front
[__] door
Jesus who wants to enter through the
back door
Mr Ramsey is here I need you to do room
one right away
[Music]
at least this door's open finally hello
there how are you how are you Mr M black
Gordon please
Robert Dean we uh were you over there I
was at the front door yes okay this is
actually our entrance and in the winter
because of snow ready we have to keep
that locked well otherwise the snow load
comes off and kills people kills people
yeah it can have you killed anyone so no
where's all this stuff from
um
an aftermath of a antiques Fair yeah
this looks like it could be a beautiful
room but you can't tell because it's
stuck with so much clutter that's the
reception desk no my dad said what is
that that is our bar right now you are
kidding me this is the bar yes with what
the martinis martinis yeah God bless him
uh made of pigs Pig Martini well we have
three rescue pot bellied picks you have
three pigs here right
what is that for were you born with this
in your mouth yeah I don't like whiz
honestly I actually know that was a gift
from a giant so yeah Robert obviously
loves to show off all his expensive
antiques but as a guest I don't feel
comfortable I feel like I'm in the
museum
this is the main formal dining room this
big chair here is four for one uh just
kind of we're known as a romantic
destination and uh it's just out of
Interest well we would move the table
move it in for me please yes
wow so you've got a sofa on the table we
thought it was kind of nice to have like
a cozy banquet
oh
three US presidents have died here oh
really which ones uh Teddy Roosevelt
Calvin Coolidge Teddy Roosevelt died in
here wow I wanted to try to give him a
little bit of sense of the history of
juniper Hill wow okay so that's the
dining room well we have two dining
rooms oh God you must be busy with two
dining rooms well I wish we were busy
let's see how we have spurts of being
incredibly busy right uh where we lack
is all the other times ready yeah
this place looks like a millionaires
Mansion not a struggling business I've
got to scratch beneath the surface this
place per week is telling how much we're
lucky if we're doing you know 15 000 a
month what does it cost to keep the
place open
30. ready yep
so you're losing
two hundred thousand dollars a year it's
been a nightmare we maintained our room
rates thinking that the economy wouldn't
be this long a haul we've all
experienced those kind of difficulties
and myself including but you you
navigate your way out of that recession
unfortunately my partner lost his job we
expected him to have his job for a
little longer he must have gained a
substantial payoff retirement it's all
been put into this how much
over a million dollars a million dollars
into this already Yes and does he have
an active role in the business he tries
to maintain the accounting and he helps
just about with everything we're in
trouble
you'd never guess when they look at
the look it's more like Buckingham
Palace than Skid Row do you know what um
Robert honestly I had to go straight to
my room if you would okay all right wow
this goes on it does it's the largest
culinary Revival Mansion in New England
more paintings and you're in the Maxwell
at Art Suite which is the original uh
okay wow beautiful room
and uh
I mean this is uh
it's a beautiful room but what is that
smell I mean seriously it's it does
smell
[__]
I mean that is horrific oh my God it
smells like sewage
where's the reception
[Music]
right anyone in
like a hallway not a chicken desk unless
she's behind there hello hello
somebody's ashes are down there
my granddad's house hello
at where's the reception ah this is it
basically this is it the receptionist
should be out in a minute if you like
okay thank you very much well hello nice
to see you it's nice to see you I'm
Karen motion it's a pleasure to meet you
I'm a little bit nervous then yeah
on my own oh well I'm sorry I apologize
for that
um it's confusing where's the reception
desk it's right here right this was the
reception desk can I just couldn't show
you something yes
and now I don't mind getting stuck in
well
oh damn oh dear oh dear that is pretty
bad yeah that's not very pleasant that's
not at all Pleasant
uh so would you like to go to your room
uh yeah follow me this way okay how old
is this place this hotel was built
around 1880s I think it was decorated in
1980s it kind of looks that way for the
first time in the last time it's been a
while for the rooms there is a closet
over here
special hangers just for me oh yep
wow wow I think the court will stay
what is that
extra carpeting we just got new carpet
in here okay so it's uh save for repairs
I've never had free carpet in my water
before okay just check my view oh look
at those bugs and the blue bottle is
staying for the week
there's like a little Forest of them
down here we give these to your cleaner
sorry uh
it's like an insect Funeral Home
truthfully in the fall there was like a
ladybug problem you're bringing it in
guest and oh my gosh it'll be like you
know 50 bucks in the room and so Ken and
I would take care of that to get rid of
the ladybugs for the people to stay
um now they've died and look at this
here
I think that's a cockroach to welcome me
on the toilet no way having a number two
I'm just like I can't believe it look at
that never had a cockroach committee
welcome me on the John let's get out of
here well what else is on this floor
well this is the owner's quarters and
all these bits of furniture here do
people literally sit that seems to work
well to cover internet service out here
okay so this is the Wi-Fi chair yes it
really is I'm going to bear that in mind
if I need to check my emails
[Music]
it's so sketchy at best okay far worse
than I thought through Gordon's eyes I
was like whoa it's totally neglected no
I will uh I'll unpack and get ready for
dinner okay
[Music]
welcome to Milford and it's a joke
how'd it go it was horrible the place is
building something
my first impressions of the yin have
been Dreadful at least I can take my
mind off things with some TV nothing
look at that I knew those shitty hangers
would come in useful for something
come on I can't believe Mr Simpsons come
on damn
is embarrassing 110 for this [__] all
it's the general hygiene cleanliness is
just shocking
wardrobe's full of crap and there's no
excuse
dead insects and filth everywhere it's
like they've given up and no one knows
there's a hotel here because it's just
not fit
to rent these rooms out for the public I
mean look at it
this is what the bedrooms are like God
knows what dinner's going to be like I
have zero resources pretty much
everything there is to do here I do it
how glamorous is this
it's a hail operations here to be honest
and he's constantly adding ideas he's
seen elsewhere but that's hurting the
hotel and the restaurant I believe our
menu is [__] joke it's like four
pages long which are all favorites of
Eddie's but we're not feeding a [__]
million different Eddies we're feeding
different people
if there's something I want on the menu
Chef's gonna do it yeah I think
Eddie will come in and say I want a
chicken parm slider on the menu I had
one in New York and I say yes I have
stopped being proud of my food
the hotel is millions of dollars in debt
and struggling to fill the rooms so I
have my work cut out for me if I'm gonna
get this place back on track we're
losing a lot of money it's a nightmare
but you should be able to handle that
Eddie knows he's losing money I just
don't think he knows how to fix it I
don't have any hope that things will get
better if anything Works around here
it's because of pure dumb luck
[Music]
there it is
a Keating wow looks nice on the outside
beautiful
Jesus is that a dog outside
hello how are you
is that a model dog was he real no she's
real what's her name smudge oh my God
she's ugly
looks like a nightclub out there with
those ropes hello how are you good to
see you
there's a lot of red
come on I'm Christos Christos good to
see you um what'd you do here life still
concierge down here at the front desk
you'll be advising me for my life are
you going to be you need dinner
reservations so you organize everything
anything you need oh now somebody likes
red is that smudge is it nice red or no
it's both the designer and the owner wow
wow
we're on the second floor second floor
please perfect thank you
right here I like to always stop at the
car each floor has a different model car
who's obsessed with the supercars who is
that the owner everybody so right here
this is your room
oh yes it's so empty more like a garage
in the guest room
and how much is this now 759
759 wow that's incredibly expensive
what's that thing there that is actually
the jacuzzi tub in the middle of the
lounge it is in the middle Lounge wow
when they designed the rooms they took
away all the interior walls but without
sounding stupid these are car designers
correct they are car designers now they
put in Jacuzzis in the middle of suite
last time I checked a living room was
for sitting it not taking a bath how
much do these things cost the jacuzzi
tub itself is about twenty thousand
dollars if you don't take baths
this is crazy who wanted all the special
designs that's Eddie that's Eddie yes
this is crazy
sports car inspired Furniture looks
cheap and isn't even functional it's
different than anything else
um different from a nice hotel room oh I
don't know about that who on Earth want
to sit here
and sort of watch the television and
watch the television
it works though
the sheets how can they also wrinkle
when having you slept in there why is
that we do them in-house we say we what
do you mean you don't do laundry
lifestyle means everything your
mouthwash it's like gas socket's all
broken on smashed down there's someone's
left their dirty ones there the plastic
plants that's outrageous 800 oh my gosh
Gordon doesn't like anything about the
hotel damn it anything else if I have
any lifestyle needs I'll call thank you
of course